Kanye West to buy right-wing social
media platform parlor owner says this is
an Insider story okay and this was all
over social yesterday Kanye West has
entered into a deal to bipolar
right-wing social media service that
builds itself as a free speech platform
its owners said Monday Parliament
Technologies announced the news saying
that the deal would help create an un uh
cancelable ecosystem where all voices
are welcome West set in a world where
conservative opinions are considered to
be controversial we have to make sure we
have the right to freely express
ourselves
Parliament technology CEO George farmer
said that the company would be honored
to help him achieve his goals West has
recently lucked out of his Twitter
account after he posted saying that he
would go death country on Jewish people
Tom when you heard this news what's the
first thing he thought about
um well Kanye needs a megaphone and no
one's given him one so he's gonna go buy
one for himself but I think he also does
believe in this is hey you know you
shouldn't be shut down for free speech
even though some of the things you've
said is like Kanye there's free speech
and then there's just crazy dumb
comments that just are just way over the
top but I think he's going out there
trying to establish a megaphone so that
people could be there people have to
remember what took parlor down wasn't
um
what took parlor down was a denial of
access to infrastructure the cert there
their server contracts were cut by
Amazon so I mean when these things go up
it's the The Playbook now is put
pressure on on the infrastructure side
and it just turns you off so you know
countdown you know can he buy this can
he a megaphone for himself but as soon
as he upset somebody they're going to
come after and they're just going to try
to turn servers off because that's a
game or and take them out of the App
Store it's so easy you know you have the
Apple App Store Google Android market
those two and infrastructure are up
there does anybody know who owns parlor
like who George farmer is
do you know who he is he's canned his
own's husband ah
yeah he owns what
it's the he's the guy that makes a lot
more sense now parlor yeah yeah I mean
just like if you want to connect the
dots yeah that's Candace Jones husband
right there what do you think about this
you see you think this is I have a lot
of friends that are big fans of Kanye
West and so you know exactly like Tom
said I think Kanye West does some dumb
things but he's an entrepreneur uh he is
smart and I do appreciate someone that
pushes back on systems where it may not
be a popular opinion and he seems to do
that pretty regularly so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]